at Blizzcon 2016 you got to hear about
some of the first details for the
necromancer in Diablo 3 and now here at
GDC 2017 we actually got to play it a
little bit more and it felt pretty
expensive we got a lot more a lot more
details about how the class is actually
going to play this time yeah it was at
least this time around your six skills
most of them were ruined unlike last
time as well as we got to see a
different flavor of a necromancer
whereas the one we saw Blizzcon was more
of like the commander your traditional
you know you had your army of skeletons
and whatnot this build this time around
at GDC was more focused on a melee man
sir which one of the abilities that we
were showing off was the grim sight
which kind of reminded me of sweep from
the Crusaders just this huge sight that
kind of goes like almost 180 degrees in
front of you a huge arcing swing that
one didn't have a ruin on it but that
was just to restore your essence
essentially which is like your mana pool
for the necro for me the big new power
was Blood Nova that that's the thing
that was so much more comparable to the
bringing the army of the Dead that we
saw from the ranged class the Blood Nova
lets you shoot out literal pools of
blood like Stanley Kubrick style waves
of blood washing over you and killing
your enemies it it's a really effective
close-range attack yeah it was like a
very big wide AoE around you almost like
a forced push from the wizard if you can
imagine that but you can see it here
just waves of blood doing a big AoE
damage it also takes from your health
which is kind of like the essence of
like a necro you know like kind of
trying to build upon that is what
Blizzard kind of talked to us about was
you know kind of what it was like to use
that blood power essentially and that's
kind of what this build was around and
one of the new things too is the Golem
that you normally see we got the blood
room this time so we had the blood golem
he's pretty cool he's kind of this
hulking mass of you know meat and flesh
that's crazy-looking essentially so
you're able to summon him in different
areas of when you be summon him he's
actually losing the life power from the
enemies around him to reform his body
yes so not only does he shoot out these
tentacles that do damage to all the
nearby enemies that you teleport him to
but he's also
entering your health which is part of
like this kind of like blood mail a
mansard bill that we got to see so you
know your blood your blood Nova would
take your life away you could use your
blood golem to then get your life back
but on top of that there was also the
ability called devourer now devourer
with the ruin that we had would take all
the like life essence from all the
bodies that you had killed or enemies
that you had killed and that would also
help restore your health yeah I felt
like this build gave us a much better
look at it both what separates that
class from the witch doctor and also
that core conceit of being a necromancer
of using the power of the Dead the power
of blood and bone and in getting a real
gameplay sense for how that works out so
when we played this build at Blizzcon I
I think you were a little bit less
impressed with necromancer how do you
feel about it now getting to play the
melee version of this class it was a lot
more fun this time around just having
the ruins and the active abilities is
like the core of Diablo 3 right like
it's what makes it fun so this time
around it was a lot more fun it was a
more full-fledged experience with an
echo in my opinion and the abilities are
really cool just interested to see you
know all the legendaries and you know
armors and weapons that kind of enhance
these builds and make them crazier so
talking with the devs about this
expansion it sounds like it's going to
be more than than just a character
there's going to be in an expansion that
this are going to be some more story
there's going to be some additional
aspect of this whether that means it's
actually full new story or whether it's
a different way for the necromancer to
interact with the events of Diablo 3
it's a isn't unclear but what do you
think we're going to get out of this
necromancer expansion really tough to
say we know definitely we're going to
get a character we're gonna get some new
legendaries new weapon type new offhand
type but but other than that it's hard
to say I really wish that would commit
to just saying like hey yeah you're
going to get a new story experience
you're going to get like a whole new
maybe act you know to kind of supplement
that because if this is an expansion you
know you like when we got the Crusader
we got a whole new Act right we got a
whole new area to play with not just one
map or tile set so really hoping that we
I can get that but you know they haven't
really spoke about it which kind of
makes me worry so we don't have a final
release date on when this expansion is
going to be out in the wild but you know
this is going to be coming to peach er
really soon so your going to be able to
try out this version of the necromancer
yourself and for even more content
around Diablo 3 and this necromancer
update be sure to stay tuned to games by
com light and subscribe the video and
tell us what you think about the
necromancer class itself in the comments
below